Emmitt Smith here on behalf of tequila
Herradura here on the richer they need
some of that before they go to vote
maybe to help influence in some kind of
way that one I gotta be honest with you
that one's a little surprising to me
well you know you know what's the cowboy
hate it is I mean it's the same way even
in Hall of Fame I mean come on Jude
Pearson husband of how great was but by
the way how great was that moment in
Philadelphia Draft excellent moment I
think that propelled Philadelphia to
where they are today so they needed some
inspiration they drew you actually set
it off the right way now one of your
triplets who I know very very well
because I work with him all the time
Michael Irvin in that chair on Monday
saying that he in a way wants the eagles
to win because it would prevent the
Patriots from having a second stint of
three Super Bowls in four years when you
would surpass everybody the one well it
would surpass the three and four you're
the only other team other than the
Patriots to do it yeah and they would be
the first to do it twice and thus maybe
knocking the Cowboys down a peg what do
you think about that that the Eagles
could help the Cowboys legacy your
thoughts Emmet's well my thoughts are
you know sure that's one aspect of it
that's not how I'm looking at I like the
Eagles because okay number one I believe
defenses win championships and I think
the Eagles is built inside out I think
the office on line and a defensive line
is extremely extremely good especially
the defensive front defense front is
unbelievable I haven't seen their
defense in front this good since the
buddy Ryan days with Jerome Brown and
rest know yeah yeah I haven't seen him
play like that
these guys here plan and have plays
solid football they put in my pain they
played the most consistent football out
of all the teams in the National Palace
year even with the loss of Carson Wentz
and and so forth so defensively this
team is built for games like this so you
think they are going to win this game
yes I do think they're gonna win this
game I think that offensively with the
running game between Jahi and and
blunt in and the third guy that they
actually have it in Nick foes when I
look at coaches and I'm asking myself
the question are they making the right
decisions are they making the right
adjustments and so when wince went down
the question was can Nick Foles do it
because everybody at mine said
Philadelphia's done including myself but
then what I saw was the coaches made an
adjustment they're just the Dolphins to
Nick Foles capabilities and started
leveraging his abilities to do a number
of different things with the ball with
the rpoS and everything else which they
already had but Nick Foles is a better
quarterback than most people want to
give him credit for because we all
remember his days with Kelly which was
not so good and so when you move on
everybody have the tendency to thing
that you're not that not that guy but
when you have coaches and sometimes you
fit in the system sometimes you don't
and they just didn't work out in that
system so people automatically assume
that he can play not think he can
so Emmitt Smith here on the Richardson
show so many people have been coming
here saying Eagles are this you use the
word solid to describe them um you're
not the first one to just use the word
solid which i think is infused with a
little bit of negativity because they're
not championship quality you but you
think that they're as good as the
previous that you've mentioned some
pretty big names like Jerome Brown right
okay all that's it everybody has said
that stuff about them and then say well
there's Tom Brady now I know you think
that I'm such a Michigan home or because
my guys beat your Gators to kick off the
season okay see how he can't even I
can't even bring it up I'm sorry I don't
even look at you it didn't you know but
all that said I mean you don't think
Brady's a great equalizer here oh I know
he is there's no doubt about it and
here's the beautiful thing about what I
love about Tom Brady in the New England
Patriots is you take 16 years of body of
work like Tom Brady has produced but you
also have to look at the eight super
bows that he has participated as
incredible which is absolutely
incredible and one would think naturally
not to bet against a Tom Brady kind of
guy and when you say that you have to
think about the best quarterback to have
ever played the game is Tom
brain in my opinion without a doubt but
I gotta give a little bit of the credit
to I got to give the leeway over here to
the Eagles in their defense so again I'm
looking at the Eagles defense and saying
man I actually believe in this defense
in a way that that can really transform
a game and and Brady with Jackson we've
got some pressure and this team here is
gonna come with just as much pressure if
not more pressure and all around
offensively as well as defensively
special teams wise the Eagles is much
much more solid team and so when I see
that I'm like pressure after pressure
after pressure
knock down up to knock down at the knock
down against Brady it could be tough it
could be tough and he's not as a young
Tom Brady as he once was and and so I'm
uh I'm giving me the Eagles are not
because I love Tom Brady don't get me
wrong he's the best of the best but that
defense doesn't have to scheme their way
to him and to me just baby maybe and
that Fletcher Cox is no joke at the end
of the day he's incredible yes and he
can get the pressure up the middle which
is the problem with rady obviously in
his losses that's that's the formula and
that has been the formula and so but
when I look at Brady in in the Patriots
and and Belichick and mr. Kraft they
have proven time and time again rich
this is what an excellent organizations
post look like from a consistency
standpoint and a systemic standpoint
they have produced eight Super Bowl
appearances in 16 years that's the
ability to have a short-term memory but
enjoy the moment but yeah get refocused
and and and and and put all your energy
towards the big prize when that is
creating something that has never been
created before and do things that others
have never done before in the three
minutes I have left with you I
definitely want to talk about your
tequila but what do you think the
Cowboys need to do need to get focused I
mean really focus and quiet all the
noise and get some of the business
things that can be done right now get it
behind them and bring in a consensus
have the team start to buy into where
the vision of the organization is really
going and spending that energy trying to
build that chemistry that's required so
who's not focused though when you say
that get focus that means somebody what
I mean what I mean is not have these
distractions not be worrying about
whether or not there's Brian is gonna be
a cowboy or not and whether or not his
contract is going gonna be there and
stuff like that worrying about this and
things that you shouldn't even have to
be thinking about I see it oftentimes
happening with teams and organizations
where like the Steelers last year
dealing with levy on bales contract and
so forth and on and on all of the
different sidebar conversations that
your teammates have to address when they
shouldn't really have to deal with those
type of things I said I happened with
with the Seattle Seahawks I mean when
you're dealing with with uh you know
your defensive back whether or not he's
gonna be there or not and so just stuff
that just messes with team chemistry
kind of happened back in in 92 or 93
back back when I missed the first two
games but what was the purpose what was
the purpose when I have proven that I
earned the right to ask for a contract
that the B should be XYZ but going
through that process affects our team
actually not only played but their
confidence level because they don't have
all of the tools in place and so you you
remove all these distractions you keep
everybody focused on the mission and you
start to work on buying into the system
and this is how we're gonna do it and
we're gonna do it professionally Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady and Bob Kraft
had done it better than most and that's
when I look at that organization I said
this is a high performance organization
period they're very consistent about it
and every man that comes into that
organization knows and have a level of
expectation that they must meet and they
manage it on and off the field - alright
last minute I have four tell me about
this tequila tequila Herradura am I
saying keel headed or is the best
tequila in the entire world I mean the
distillery process that they go through
at one of the at
the only Hacienda that produces this
tequila or the real tequila that is this
today the true Hacienda that whole
entire process of in fermentation is
amazing they don't cut any corners and
they managed twenty thousand acres of
agave plants where they're fully mature
it takes about seven years for them to
fully get mature then they go and
extract it and go through the whole
entire process to create this beautiful
tequila and so when you think about
headed or you have to think about
excellence you think about champions you
think about something that's that's pure
that that that when you go through they
aged a little bit longer than most they
they go beyond the standards to make
sure that it's quality and this is what
this tequila is all about it's about
greatness all right check it out on
Facebook at Herradura tequila then drink
responsibly
of course good to see you and good to
see you always good to see you let me
know when you're back in Los Angeles we
please well do let's do it
that's a Emmitt Smith 22 on Twitter I
followed him there three times Super
Bowl champion Pro Football Hall of Famer
and as a record nobody's ever gonna
break Never Say Never
I'll say it I don't think anybody's
gonna break that Emmitt Smith here on
the Rich Eisen showed the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience